all right so everyone said I can't rap
they said Pearl stop it
stick to singing
you're too whatever for this
but when they say I can't go hard
I go harder
yes
I'm gonna take the topics they gave me
number one
feminism is the worst thing ever men and
women they ain't together
they told women we could do better but
then we go off and never yeah we get our
money yeah we get our job yeah we dumped
our high school heartthrob but then we
end up alone on antidepressants all
alone I know they say I'm a loser I know
they say I'm a Bruiser I know I
shouldn't call them whales but these
they got a sale now this is the
I do now this is the IOU feminism
is the end of the family unit let's not
play pretend look they got the fathers
out of the home they said when in Rome
you're a boss babe you can do it
yourself girl you don't need nobody else
I just need me myself and I
hold on
look it look it
I just need me myself and I when I talk
these cry they got me wondering
why
I'm talking like
girl it's not left or right girl it's
not black and white this is the fight we
gotta fight
but out of sight out of sight out of
mind I'm always trying to be kind I wish
we could press rewind and take away the
vote I wouldn't mind look because this
is what they do to the women really
women are children they're getting our
ears on social media and all they'll do
is brainwash y'all say women or men and
men are women they really treat us like
adult children you did nothing wrong
girl you're a queen and now I'm mean for
saying no you're fat you're kind of a
hoe but they'll like whoa whoa whoa you
better not go go go and say the truth
even though we know no no no and maybe
they act real slow and maybe they act
real tough but all of these goddamn
stamps do the same thing and it's kind
of rough like this is what they'll say
they'll say get to work you boss babe
they'll say do what you want the streets
are calling young and free and wild and
me all of this is just me me me all
of this breaks up the family
breaks up the family
one two three four five get on the road
maybe go and drive get on the road maybe
you'll thrive
let it slide
and that's what they do
no standards too
[Music]
okay
the Stamps though they're just as bad
they lie to you that's what I said they
said men don't care about your body
count be fat Queen let it out it's like
you know this it ain't true you
know this is what they do you know this
is real rude you know this
ain't brand new now
oh wait that's the end okay you know you
could call me a rapper should I keep
going I all right I swore a little more
than I'm proud of in that one but
sometimes it just comes let me know guys
one to ten am I getting better